gamers are undoubtedly a nostalgic bunch
so it's no surprise that reissues have
become a sort of genre unto themselves
worthy of their very own game of the
year category and with so many old
favorites made new it also makes sense
that some remasters outshine the others
that's why we've selected the five
finest reissues of 2015 based not only
on how much we loved the original games
but also on how well those games were
revamped for the modern era perhaps the
best example of a remastered total
package is the 3ds version of The Legend
of Zelda Majora's Mask the original
launched 15 years ago on the Nintendo 64
so needless to say the game's graphics
and audio have not aged well dat all
thankfully Majora's Mask 3d salvaged
both and even more impressively it fully
utilised 3ds unique functionality by
adding touchscreen controls gyroscopic
features and of course optional 3d
visuals but most importantly Majora's
Mask 3d allowed the game to finally step
out of Ocarina of Time shadow and enjoy
some of the recognition it's slowly
garnered over the past decade and a half
cult classic Grim Fandango digital
remaster for PC ps4 and PS vita provided
a similar Second Life while the original
release achieved only modest commercial
success gamers gradually grew to
appreciate the inventive premise McCobb
humor and endearing characters of
developer Tim savers signature creation
as that appreciation spread so did the
public's appetite for more Fandango the
reissue scratch that itch with style by
updating the game's visuals and
providing hours of developer commentary
being an adventure game from 1998 many
of the puzzles felt oddly impenetrable
by modern standards but in spite of its
shortcomings Grim Fandango remastered
gave us exactly what we wanted any
excuse to play Grim Fandango guess they
couldn't save Mia no but there's still a
chance you could save me the same can be
said of both journeys digital re-release
on ps4 and grand theft auto 5 SPC launch
while journey received no updates beyond
a basic resolution and frame rate bump
its arrival on Sony's current console
gave everyone another chance to indulge
in its brief but utterly engrossing
experience one that earned an
exceptionally rare 10 out of 10 review
score when it launched this past July
and while GTA 5's PC release also made
only minor changes to the game's core
content it did allow more players access
to one of the greatest open-world
variances of all time while also opening
the door for the modern community to
create a guy user of home-brewed content
at a time when PC ports seem to
routinely fall short of their console
counterparts we have to applaud rockstar
for ensuring GTA 5's pc version didn't
suffer the same fate even if it did take
a little longer than we expected finally
DMC definitive edition gave us a
slightly different example of what
reissues do well by packing a wealth of
content including new costumes new
gameplay mechanics and all previously
released DLC onto a single disk DMC
already packed plenty of Appeal thanks
to its nuanced skill based combat but by
packaging together every piece of
content imaginable Capcom gave fans
another reason to overlook the widely
reviled redesign of lead character Dante
thanks to reissues the past has never
looked so good and with remastered
versions of day of the tentacle heavy
rain and many more already announced for
2016 we're confident the reissue
category will have an equally strong
showing at next year's Game of the Year
awards
you